اعلنت الصين عن زياده ميزانيتها العسكريه
بالنسبه
27% هذا العام
متجاوزه موازنه العام الماضي تجاوزا طفيفا
وقال رئيس الوزراء الصيني امام البرلمان
انه لابد من تنسيق العمليات العسكريه
وبناء القدرات والاستعداد التام للقتال
واشدد رئيس الحكومه الصينيه على ضروره
تطوير العلاقات السلميه ودفع اعاده
التوحيد السلمي مع اتخاذ خطوات حازمه لمنع
استقلال التايوان
تايوان دعت اليوم الاحد الصين الى احترام
التزام الشعب التايواني بالمفاهيم
الاساسيه للسياده والديمقراطيه والحريه
وقال مجلس شؤون السياسه الصينيه في تايوان
في بيان ان على الصين معالجه الامور عبر
مضيق تايوان بطريقه عمليه وعقلانيه
ومتساويه ومحترمه للطرفين
ياتي موقفه تايوان ردا على تصريحات رئيس
الوزراء الصيني لكيانجا اليوم قال فيه انه
تصريحات قال فيها انه يتعين على الحكومه
ان تعزز التنميه السلميه للعلاقات مع
تايوان وعمليه ما سماها اعاده التوحيد
السلمي للصين وكذلك ان تتخذ خطوات حازمه
لمعارضه استقلالي تايوان
مكتب الجزيره ناصر عبد الحق وناصر نود ان
نسالك عن خطاب رئيس الوزراء الصيني الذي
القاه امام المجلس الوطني لنواب الشعب
الصيني خاصه تلك المتعلقه بالانفاق
العسكري وتايوان
نعم عثمان حقيقه خطاب رئيس الوزراء لهذا
العام كالعاده جاء في معظمه
ركز على الوضع الاقتصادي والوضع الاجتماعي
حيث اعلن وضع اهدافا للنمو الاقتصادي في
العام المقبل لا تتجاوز 5% بالاضافه الى
التجديد على وحده الامه والشعب الصيني
بجميع اقلياتها ربما في اشاره الى
الاضطرابات في اقليم شنجان وقال بان جميع
الاقليات عليها ان تنتج تحت الثقافه
وثقافه الامه الصينيه
جاءت الاعلان عن الميزانيه العسكريه
مخالفا لتوقعات الكثير من المراقبين حقيقه
في ظل هذه التوترات التي تحيط بالصين سواء
في بحر جنوب الصين او عبر مضيق تايوان او
في بحر شرق الصين حيث كان المتوقع ان تكون
الميزانيه العسكريه لهذا العام اكبر واعلى
من مثيلاتها في الاعوام السابقه لكنها
جاءت اعلى بقليل بعشر في المئه فقط مقارنه
بالعام الماضي لكن هناك خبراء يرون بان
هذا طبيعي لان الميزانيه العسكريه تتناسب
عاده طرديا مع
الدخل القومي او اعلان الاهداف الاقتصاديه
للدوله حيث ان الاقتصاد هو من عندما يكون
قويا تكون الدوله بامكانها الانفاق اكثر
على قدراتها العسكريه هذا من جهه من جهه
اخرى طالما نفت الصين بان تطوير قدراتها
العسكريه وميزانيتها العسكريه هي فقط من
اجل الدفاع وليست تستهدف اي طرف اخر وذلك
على الرغم من ان الصين شهدت خلال السنوات
الماضيه التطورا او تطويرا محموما
لقدراتها العسكريه وادخلت عليها العديد من
التق سواء في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي او في
مجال الفضاء او في مجال تطوير الطائرات
الشبحيه وكل ذلك ياتي كما يقول المراقبون
في ظل التحديات التي تواجهها الصين خلال
السنوات الاخيره سواء عبر مضيق تايوان حيث
شهدت الجزيره توترا ملحوظا منذ زياره
الزياره التي
قامت بها نانسي بلوزو الى جزيره تايوان
والمواجهه مع الولايات المتحده شكرا جزيلا
لك مكتب الجزيره ناصر